[Música]
para vivir esta conferencia
mi hermosa mira
me pregunto qué pasa
no estable
y le dije voy a darlo con place y para
explicarle que una conferencia
y me dijo ahorita no tiene susto
fue la voz
sin embargo teniendo tenía que superar
el desafío
y quería compartir con ustedes
una historia con el propósito de motivar
incentivada muchos
para que se anime
y
en la pobreza
y sobre todo lo que es también
igual espero que lo haga bien
la pobreza
con una actitud de indolencia o
despreocupación
una posición
o trasladar esa preocupación a opel
trasladar la preocupación hacer a la
acción
solamente se trasladamos esta
preocupación acción podemos pensar en
la pobreza
está entre nosotros
simplemente hasta sentadas
convivimos
la vemos todos los días
que a fuerza de ver nos hemos
acostumbrado
y pasa desapercibido
en mi primer viaje a la nieve
para conocer el programa de grammy
me sobrecogió la pobreza en la que
en un momento en que te sorprende
si la pobreza en américa tierra
específicamente
entendía el error que estaba emitiendo
estamos juzgando a las mujeres estaba
estaba visitando las estaban sus
parientes
por supuesto que es tu apariencia y la
diferente
a las mujeres de nuestros países
sin embargo con el tiempo presentarme y
compartir con sus problemas
inmediatamente
que las series de la pobreza es igual en
todo
con leves diferencias los estímulos
la falta de esos básicos
la falta de posibilidad de ser derechos
humanos
en una similar
si atendemos en internet
audiencia nos engañamos
porque no con segmentos
si nos enfocamos
qué van a hacer cambios sostenibles
la pobreza
es un defecto
así un defecto
la sociedad
todos somos
dos distintas es que la perpetua o quien
la solución a pensar en positivo todos
si todos nosotros ricos pobres más ricos
suman fuerzas en cables y vamos a poder
crear círculos
y el rostro
cuando revisamos el procesado
inmediatamente nos vienen
la idea de caridad beneficencia
donaciones
a nivel de los estados
suicidios bordes
claro en estas acciones
aliviar momentáneamente hombres
también el disimulo
en américa latina
los programas de donación
están no solamente dando enormes
no están teniendo resultados
personas caen en una dependencia que es
realmente duros
tienen
confianza en ellos mismos
que tienen el deseo lo que yo quiero
y desarrollo humano
en programas de desarrollo carlos puerto
de redes sociales
y los que se enfocan
grandes
ocáriz su intervención primero en la
novela de la necesidad
y no se desvían de por sí
si comienzan a tapar con jóvenes y
después porque resulta difícil porque
están lejos porque no es rentable
desvían su atención
pero más
focalizados de darles lo que necesitan
con ellos hacer que este bloque
el servicio que van a recibir explicar
resultados
y rendir cuentas resultados para
conseguir con la institución no
solamente cultura sino en los mismos
equipos
no antes
que se ha avanzado y se da cuenta que de
200 millones que son las que vivían en
pobreza
tienen 2014 se ha reducido más 160
del 14 al 16
a su vida
75 millones de personas en américa que
viven en condición de pobreza sin ser
amados
esta es una llamada de atención
se traduce en un 30% personas en américa
latina no tienen
que viven al mar
paradójicamente estas son centro de
oportunidades
se puede traducir en una enorme
oportunidad
para personas como ustedes que tienen
más dioses
cree a sí mismos entre falta de
oportunidades yo
para crear un círculo virtuoso de
inclusión financiera
de normalización para las cuestiones que
necesitan la oportunidades
para ustedes es para dar una sensación
de pimienta
motivo
y terminó la misión
ustedes tienen un privilegio enorme
como otros miles acceso
educación de incae
se espera lo mejor
seguro que todos ustedes van a adquirir
un excelente puesto de trabajo y van a
tener un salario muy bueno pero sobre
todo van a tener posiciones mucho más
esa es una opción
spears y les recomiendo que desde esa
posición
no miren a la pobre
adapta
pero también existe la posibilidad
en vez de buscar
cree
solo
yo sé que todos ustedes todos los
jóvenes las personas que están
e insertando en la vida laboral de
quienes tienen
capacidad de innovación de crear para
poder hacer no es fácil es difícil
menor
yo doy gracias a la vida y además de
unión inglés
me han habido en todas las puertas de
américa latina
para demostrar si se puede ser volcado
que si se puede hacer una despedida
sus hijos están en condiciones
entonces quiero pedirles que si es un
camino que recorrer
mil veces
satisfacción podría retirar los 30 años
de trabajo suficiente no es un visto
porque vivo me alimento de la felicidad
de ver cambios
cuándo
más cambio
en sus hijos mientras mis nietos
un mundo de paz
por educación letras jueves para
el 30 y apoyar
iluminación
ah
[Aplausos]